und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und eine Gellinek
guten Abend das mit dem vorösterlichen
Frieden in der Ampelkoalition ist schief
gegangen die Freude über einen schnell
verabredeten Gesetzentwurf zum
heizungsaustausch Werte nur bis zum
nächsten Zeitungsinterview des FTP
Finanzministers Christian Lindner lobt
darin zwar die Einigung auf Regeln für
die Klimawende sticht aber sogleich ins
nächste Wespennest die Kinder
Grundsicherung ein herzensthema der
Grünen verortet der Finanzminister unter
Projekten die wünschenswert aber derzeit
nicht realisierbar sein tja dass die
Grünen das nicht lustig finden ist auch
klar Nicole Diekmann über neuen Streit
zwischen den immer gleichen
Koalitionspartnern
ein warmes Essen am Tag für viele Kinder
gibt es das nur dank Hilfsprojekten ein
Instrument im Kampf gegen Kinderarmut
ist die Kindergrundsicherung ihre Reform
hat sich die Ampel in den
Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben die
Kindergrundsicherung ist das
sozialpolitische Projekt dieser
Koalition und deswegen muss sie auch ein
klares Signal senden an die Ärmsten
unserer Gesellschaft dass sie
unterstützt werden und deswegen müssen
wir da auch über relevantes Geld reden
aber die Ampel redet nicht sondern sie
streitet die Ministerin will die
Leistungen ausweiten und fordert 12
Milliarden heute erneut klare Absage vom
Bundesfinanzminister der unter anderem
auf das bereits erhöhte Kindergeld
verweist insgesamt stellen wir Familien
und Kindern sieben Milliarden Euro pro
Jahr mehr zur Verfügung das Wesentliche
für die Kindergrundsicherung ist damit
finanziell getan mehr ist immer
wünschenswert aber nicht immer möglich
die SPD springt Lindner zur Seite es
gehe nicht darum die Zahl der
Anspruchsberechtigten zu steigern
sondern die Zahl derer die die Kinder
Grundsicherung auch wirklich beantragen
derzeit ist es so dass nur etwa ein
Drittel der Eltern und Kinder die den
Kinderzuschlag bekommen könnten ihn
tatsächlich auch beantragen weil es
einfach zu kompliziert ist und weil die
Leute auch was anderes zu tun haben
Sozialverbände üben massive Kritik
die Familienministerin hat ca 12
Milliarden Euro angemeldet für die
Kindergrundsicherung und ich finde
darüber sollte jetzt nicht verhandelt
und gefalgt werden sondern hier geht es
tatsächlich um ein Projekt des extrem
wichtig ist für Menschen und wenn ich
mich entscheiden müsste Autobahn
ausbauen Menschen fördern wer für mich
die Entscheidung klar ich würde Kinder
Jugendliche fördern jedes fünfte Kind in
Deutschland ist von Armut bedroht
während die Ampel seit Wochen über
mögliche Lösungen streitet sind sich CDU
und Linkspartei ausnahmsweise einig sie
halten keine davon für richtig
der erste Baustein muss ja sein dass wir
dafür sorgen dass Familien das Kinder
die einen Anspruch haben schon heute ihn
auch bekommen die Leistungen bekommen
und stand heute verändert sich nicht
also da gibt's keine Vorschläge wie wir
das verbessern können und erst der
zweite Schritt ist dann über die Höhe zu
diskutieren und da brauchen wir uns
ehrlich gesagt noch gar keine Gedanken
darüber machen weil sich die Ampel
selber völlig unheimlich ist wenn man
sich die Rekord Gewinne von großen
Energieunternehmen ansieht von großen
Nahrungsmittelunternehmen warum hat die
Ampel keine wirkliche übergewinnsteuer
eingeführt und damit die Einnahme Seite
des Haushalt ist gestärkt dieses Geld
brauchen wir dringend um gegen
Kinderarmut vorgehen zu können wie weit
will die Ampel sich strecken die Kinder
Grundsicherung eine weitere grundlegende
Frage in der die Koalition über Kreuz
liegt
fragen wir nach bei Theo call in Berlin
Theo warum macht Christian Lindner das
jetzt wo sich die Koalition doch gerade
zusammengerauft hatte ja ich für
Christian Lindner und für die FDP ist
die Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse
natürlich eine der Grundfesten liberaler
Programmatik und daher Krisen und
kriegsbedingt ja den finanziellen Rahmen
des Haushalts schon mehrere Male durch
gigantische Schattenhaushalte verletzt
hat steht da glaube ich jetzt nicht
zuletzt bei seiner politischen
Anhängerschaft unter scharfer
Beobachtung und die Ministerien haben
insgesamt 70 Milliarden an Zusatz
wünschen angemeldet so dass Lindner
nicht einmal wegwerfen vorliegen konnte
in dieser haushaltslogik ist es dann
eher folgerichtig für ihn dass die
Kinder Grundsicherung mit den
geforderten 12 Milliarden jährlich von
ihm den politischen kW vermerkt bekommt
also kann wegfallen
der Koalitionsausschuss hat aber
offenbar ja tiefere Wunden gerissen als
zuerst gedacht wie gefährlich ist das
für den Fortbestand der Ampel
also ich halte die Ampel nicht für akut
gefährdet aber diese dreierbeziehungen
hat jetzt den Punkt erreicht das ein
Partner in dem Fall die Grünen
schmerzhafter erfahren hat dass er auf
absehbare Zeit weniger geliebt wird
überraschenderweise auch von der ihm ja
politisch eigentlich näher stehenden SPD
der Kanzler braucht für seine Macht zwar
beide Partner aber die FDP ist
gefährdeter nach fünf verlorene
Landtagswahlen weitere Drohnen ja jetzt
muss sie sich macht strategisch aus der
5% Todeszone wegbewegen können die
Zugeständnisse im Verkehrsbereich fahren
da nebenbei eine klare Morgengabe der
SPD an die FDP und wenn das auf Kosten
des wahrscheinlichsten koalitionsintern
kanzlerkonkurrenten habe geht könnte
auch das ein willkommener Nebeneffekt
sein über Liebe und nicht Liebe in der
Ampel vielen Dank Theo Köln nach Berlin
wir können auch anders so könnte man die
neue China-Politik der EU beschreiben
bisher hatte Europa und da besonders
Deutschland mit dem China Geschäft gut
und gerne Geld verdient und
US-Forderungen nach Einschränkung des
Handels mit dem asiatischen Giganten
stets skeptisch betrachtet nun aber
scheint sich zumindest an der EU-Spitze
etwas zu verändern
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
hat einen europäischen Strategiewechsel
angekündigt es könne ja wohl nicht sein
dass europäische Firmen dem chinesischen
Unterdrückungsapparat auch noch die
passende Technologie verkauften am
Mittwoch reist von der Leyen zusammen
mit dem französischen Präsidenten macron
nach Peking zum Gespräch mit den Ping
diesmal wohl in eher unterkühlte
Atmosphäre
die Stimmung ist bei einer heiter an
diesem Montag im März da kommt ein
Partner kein lupenrenner Demokrat aber
der Herrscher über einen riesigen Markt
man redet über ein gemeinsames
Investitionsabkommen und wenig über
Probleme es ist vier Jahre her dass
Chinas Staatschef hi diese Bühne Europas
betrat seitdem hat sich viel geändert
Chinas auftreten und Europas Blick
darauf
das ist China has been Ramping
militärisch aufgerüstet hat hat es auch
seine Politik der Desinformation und des
wirtschaftlichen Drucks aufgerüstet
wir sehen dass China zu Hause
repressiver wird und im Ausland
selbstbewusster
und Europa scheint aufgewacht sieht was
China will und wogegen man sich wehren
muss wenn Ursula von der Leyen diese
Woche nach Peking reist hat sie ein
neues Werkzeug im Gepäck übt China
wirtschaftlichen Druck auf einzelne
Staaten aus dann darauf haben sich
Vertreter von Ministerrat und
EU-Parlament diese Woche geeinigt kann
Europa genauso zurückschlagen
die Patente aufheben wir können Markt
Zugangsbeschränkungen einsetzen also den
ganzen großen Kopf von Gegenmaßnahmen so
dass
Handelspartner weltweit wissen wir sind
bereit auf Zwangsmaßnahmen schnell und
klar zu reagieren das Gesetz richtet
sich das ist kein Geheimnis vor allem
gegen ein Land China das bisher nicht
auf das hört was Besucher aus Europa
fordern am Freitag Spaniens premier
franches auch dessen Appell China möge
sich von Russlands Krieg distanzieren
verhalt ohne Ergebnis
China kennt schließlich diese Zahlen zu
Europas Abhängigkeit etwa bei Rohstoffen
die Europa für die Energiewende braucht
98 Prozent der seltenen Erden die Europa
importiert kommen aus China 97% des
importierten Lithiums 93% des
importierten Magnesiums kann Europa sich
da von China entkoppeln das ist denkbar
dass man sich von solchen Dingen löst
aber es werden dramatische Einschnitt
für die Globalisierung es hätte heftige
Effekte auf Preisentwicklung es würde
die Verfügbarkeit von zentralen Gütern
natürlich nicht mehr erlauben also
insofern ist die Frage ob wir das wollen
wir müssen uns nicht und wir wollen uns
nicht entkoppeln aber Risiken minimieren
zum Beispiel indem man nicht nur von
China bezieht das ist das Gebot der
Stunde das Risiko minimieren am Rande
hat Europa darüber auch vor vier Jahren
schon gesprochen man hatte es schlicht
nicht gemacht
und wir bleiben in Europa und da wurde
heute gleich in zwei EU-Ländern gewählt
damit bin die beginnen die Nachrichten
mit Diana ja und da schauen wir zunächst
nach Finnland dort zeichnet sich nach
Schließung der Wahllokale ein enges Kopf
an Kopf Rennen zwischen den regierenden
Sozialdemokraten um Ministerpräsidentin
marien und der konservativen nationalen
Koalition ab beide liegen nach ersten
Ergebnissen mit etwa 20 Prozent der
Stimmen gleich auf dicht gefolgt von der
rechtspopulistischen Partei die finden
in dem künftigen nato-land waren etwa
4,5 Millionen Menschen zur
Parlamentswahl aufgerufen
und auch die Bulgarinnen und Bulgaren
haben heute ein neues Parlament gewählt
und zwar zum fünften Mal innerhalb von
zwei Jahren nach wahlbefragungen sehen
das liberalere Form Bündnis und die
konservative gerbpartei nahezu gleich
auf eine Regierungsbildung dürfte damit
erneut schwierig werden seit zwei Jahren
ist in dem EU-Land keine stabile
Regierung zustande gekommen Bulgarien
gilt als ernstes Land der EU und
Korruption ist ein großes Problem
sieben Wochen nach der Wiederholung der
Berliner Abgeordnetenhauswahl haben sich
CDU und SPD auf einen Koalitionsvertrag
geeinigt in der neuen Regierung sollen
beide Parteien je fünf
Senatsverwaltungen übernehmen neuer
Regierender Bürgermeister und Nachfolger
von Franziska Giffey würde CDU
landesschef Kai Wegner
das Heizen mit Gas werde in Zukunft sehr
viel teurer das hat bundesbauministerin
Gallwitz bei Berlin direkt mit Blick auf
die heizungseinigung der Ampel verkündet
der Zustand mit billigem russischen Gas
zu heizen sei nicht wiederherstellbar
mit Wärmepumpen spare man stattdessen
auf lange Sicht galwitz betonte zudem
bei möglichen Abwrackprämien für alte
Heizungen sein unbürokratische Lösungen
wichtig
bei einer Explosion in einem Café in St
Petersburg ist nach Regierungsangaben
ein Bekannter russischer kriegsblogger
ums Leben gekommen 25 Menschen wurden
bei der Detonation des sprengensatzes
verletzt der Blogger mit dem
pseudonym-harski befürwortete auf seinem
telegram-kanal den russischen Krieg
gegen die Ukraine die Hintergründe der
Explosion sind noch unklar
in Polen sind tausende Menschen auf die
Straße gegangen um den ehemaligen Papst
Johannes Paul den zweiten gegen den
Vorwurf zu verteidigen dass er
Kindesmissbrauch vertuscht habe die
Proteste sind eine Reaktion auf einen
Fernsehbeitrag der Anfang März
veröffentlicht worden war daran wird dem
früheren Papst vorgeworfen in seiner
Zeit als Erzbischof von Krakau von
Missbrauchsfällen gewusst und die Täter
geschützt zu haben
vor 60 Jahren ging das
ZDF auf Sendung erst aus Provisorien bei
Frankfurt am Main und in Wiesbaden seit
1984 dann vollständig von hier aus dem
Sendezentrum auf dem Mainzer Lerchenberg
seit es das ZDF und den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk in
Deutschland gibt gibt es auch Kritik an
ihm konservativer schwarzfunk spießig
provinziell oder aber zu Links zu grün
dieser Tiere zu frech oder zu
geschmacklos wir nehmen den 60 zum
Anlass um auf genau diese Debatte zu
schauen Christa hat sich bei Fans und
Kritikern umgehört
immer wenn großes passiert ist Fernsehen
unverzichtbar das war vor über 50 Jahren
bei der Mondlandung das wird auch so
sein wenn Menschen zum Mars fliegen live
Ereignisse menschliche Herausforderungen
oder Katastrophen gehören zum
Kerngeschäft des ZDF seit 60 Jahren seit
fast 22.000 Tagen das ZDF war für meine
Kindheit wirklich so die Babysitterin
ein Stück weit ich bin sicher mit dem
Personal des ZDF groß geworden ich kenne
die Geschichten ich kenne die Figuren
das ZDF hat Generation geprägt doch was
wird von Mainzer Sender heute nicht
alles erwartet das ZDF soll kreativ
kritisch innovativ modern
ausgewogen unabhängig divers inklusiv
transparent klar wahr und wach sein
reicht das ich würde erwarten dass das
ZDF sich selbstkritischen Frage stellt
dass das ZDF nie zufrieden ist mit dem
Erreichten Status und dass das ZDF nicht
versucht das was ein tiktok oder ein
Youtube tut eins zu eins zu kopieren das
wird nicht funktionieren erzählt man
Familiengeschichten wie erzählt man
einwanderungsgeschichten junge
Geschichten verschiedene Geschichten
vielleicht auch ohne diesen Versuch
Menschen immer was zu erklären oder zu
zeigen wie es geht sondern wirklich die
Faszination das Leben zu zeigen so wie
es in Deutschland eben auch jeden Tag
stattfindet in den Städten in den
Dörfern wo auch immer wir haben auch im
ZDF kein einziges Interview Format das
mit Behutsamkeit mit Langsamkeit
Meinungsbildung als etwas offenes
prozesshaftes
verletzliches begreift sondern wir haben
streitformate mit maximaler Rollen
Klarheit mit sofort Bescheid wissen tun
mit fertigen Position
Kritik gehört zum täglichen Brot der
öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender in letzter
Zeit wurde sie eher lauter auch das ZDF
heißt es sei so alt zu teuer zu
bürokratisch die Reizwörter lauten
Zwangsgebühren Selbstbedienung
üppige Gehälter enger meinungskorridor
Staatsnähe und Lügenpresse stimmt das
ich glaube je besser das ZDF die Mittel
die es erhält nutzt je kreativer ist es
je mehr als repräsentiert was diese
Gesellschaft sein kann kritisch auf
Themen guckt desto lieber werden
Menschen auch sagen natürlich leisten
wir uns das weil die Demokratie sich das
leisten sollte Journalismus ist nicht
mehr nur ein Beruf sondern ist
eigentlich eine Kulturtechnik die alle
angeht alle betrifft denn jeder ist
unter den gegenwärtigen
medienbedingungen in dieser gigantischen
Öffnung des kommunikativen Raumes selbst
zum Sender geworden was heißt das für
die Zukunft das ZDF für alle will im
Fernsehen und online preiswert Fakten
orientiert informativ unterhaltsam
kulturell vielseitig und verlässlich
sein aber eines soll bleiben
was immer man modernisiert beim ZDF aber
bitte nehmen sie uns niemals die
einzelnen Menschen weg
60 Jahre ZDF Grund zum feiern aber auch
Gelegenheit zur selbstkritischer
Bestandsaufnahme darüber wollen wir
reden mit ZDF intender Norbert Himmler
guten Abend hallo die gute alte Tante
ZDF wird 60 sind wir nun jung gebliebene
Rentner oder altes Eisen können wir weg
ich finde 60 ist doch ein tolles Alter
man hat eine Menge Lebenserfahrung und
man steht auch noch voll im Saft und von
daher ist das finde ich ein prima Alter
aber klar wir haben traditionelle
Programme die seit langem schon gibt das
aktuelle sportstudio terrax natürlich
und auf der anderen Seite müssen wir uns
auch mal wieder neu erfinden neue Sender
auch Kunden mit ZDFneo und Info die
Mediathek vorantreiben und das ist der
Spagat der auch noch viele Jahre uns
bestimmen wird trotzdem gibt es ja im
Moment sehr viel Kritik an den
öffentlichen rechtlichen Sendern zu
allzu schwerfällig zu teuer zu viele
Mitarbeiter was kann der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk was
andere nicht können finde dass wir diese
Kritik sehr ernst nehmen müssen weil wir
bekommen Geld von allen also müssen wir
für alle auch etwas bieten auch für alle
muss was dabei sein im
Informationsbereich tiefgründige
Recherche zum Beispiel ein gutes
Korrespondentennetz aber auch
preisgekrönte Dokumentationen
unterhaltsame Filme und Serien ich
glaube aber auch dass die Kritiker
verkennen was wir leisten als ZDF was
wir jeden Tag leisten 24 Stunden hier im
Hauptprogramm
aber auch das gesamte Angebot was wir
bieten die Digitalkanäle die
partnerkanäle den Kinderkanal zum
Beispiel die Mediathek und auch die ZDF
heute App das bekommen alle für 15 Cent
am Tag und was bekommt man wenn man an
den Kiosk geht für 15 Cent also von
daher das ist auch eine belastliche
Leistung ich wäre froh wenn man das am
Geburtstag auch sehen würde trotzdem ist
der Ton der Kritik ja schärfer geworden
wo haben die Kritiker recht wo haben wir
uns unglaubwürdig gemacht ich glaube
unglaubwürdig haben wir uns gar nicht
gemacht glaubwürdigkeit ist gerade unser
größtes gut im Journalismus aber auch in
allen anderen Bereichen aber wir müssen
um diese Glaubwürdigkeit jeden Tag
kämpfen wir müssen zusehen dass wir die
ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer auch immer
wieder überzeugen aber wir sind
unabhängig und auch die Werte zeigen
dass die Glaubwürdigkeit und sehr
zugesprochen wird gerade auch in
Krisenzeiten in der Pandemie z.B oder
jetzt auch wenn wir kriegen in Europa
haben haben wir sehr hohe
glaubwürdigkeitswerte und die müssen
aber immer wieder neue erkämpfen
Glaubwürdigkeit wird auch der ARD
zugesprochen warum also brauchen wir
denn zwei öffentlich-rechtliche Systeme
ich finde gut und wichtig dass wir zwei
verschiedene nachrichtensysteme zum
Beispiel haben hier das heute journal
was den Tag einordnet hintergründig
Informationen bietet auch Themen setzt
und das gleiche macht dann im Anschluss
dann an das heute schnell die
Tagesthemen in der ARD das sorgt für
Vielfalt sorgt aber auch gleichzeitig
für publizistischen Wettbewerb und von
daher glaube ich dass eine so große
Demokratie auch genauso etwas braucht
gerade in Zeiten von Fake News und
Falschinformationen dass wir wirklich
aufklären und mündige Bürgerinnen und
Bürger haben was sagen sie denen die uns
nicht mehr gucken die keinen Fernseher
haben die sich belehrt fühlen die den
Eindruck haben sie würden lieber Netflix
gucken und trotzdem Gebühren zahlen
müssen
merkt man glaube ich auch
Nutzerverhalten wenn man sich umschaut
das hat sich gewaltig verändert in den
letzten Jahren und wir wollen ein ZDF
für alle sein wir müssen wirklich für
alle etwas zu bieten haben und gerade
weil sich die Gewohnheiten so ändert
haben müssen wir auch darauf reagieren
in allen Jobs auch Besonderheiten
anbieten wie als hätten gerade
beschlossen 100 Millionen Euro im
Programm umzuschichten um auch genau auf
solche Zuschauer Schichten zugehen zu
können die Reichweite ist hoch die wir
haben in die Gesellschaft weit über 80%,
aber die die uns wenig sehen oder auch
selten sehen auf die müssen dazu gehen
die BBC hat angekündigt dass sie in zehn
Jahren nicht mehr im Fernsehen sondern
nur noch online senden will also wie
sieht das ZDF an seinem 70 Geburtstag
aus oder welches ZDF übergeben sie an
ihre Nachfolgerin
ich halte von diesem Prognosen nichts
das in zehn Jahren ist kein lineares
Fernsehen mehr gibt ich glaube dass man
immer gute öffentlich-rechtliche
Informationen Unterhaltung braucht egal
ob man das auf dem großen Stream sich
anschaut oder auf dem kleinen Tablet
oder Handy oder was auch immer ist in
zehn Jahren geben wird wichtig ist aber
dass wir öffentlich-rechtlichen guten
öffentlich-rechtlichen unabhängige
Rundfunk brauchen ich glaube das wichtig
für unsere Demokratie und das wird man
in 10 und 20 Jahren genauso brauchen wir
heute sagt Norbert Himmler ZDF Intendant
vielen Dank für den Besuch im Studio
danke
das Interview haben wir vor der Sendung
aufgezeichnet und wir machen hier noch
mal mit Nachrichten weiter und mit Hanna
zimmermann
bei einem schweren Verkehrsunfall in
Thüringen sind insgesamt sieben Menschen
ums Leben gekommen darunter 5 19-Jährige
drei weitere Personen wurden schwer
verletzt der Unfall ereignete sich am
Samstagnachmittag auf einer Bundesstraße
bei Bad Langensalza nach Angaben der
Polizei geriet eines der Fahrzeuge in
den Gegenverkehr der 45-jährige Fahrer
habe keinen Führerschein gehabt die
genaue Unfallursache ist allerdings noch
unklar zwei Fahrzeuge brannten komplett
aus
zum Sport und damit zunächst zu zwei
Ergebnissen aus der Fußball-Bundesliga
im reinen sich der erste fC Köln und
Borussia Mönchengladbach 0 zu 0
Unentschieden und im zweiten Spiel
unterlag Werder Bremen zu Hause der TSG
Hoffenheim mit eins zu zwei
in der Formel 1 hat Weltmeister Max
Verstappen erstmals den Großen Preis von
Australien gewonnen in einem turbulenten
Rennen lag der Red Bull Pilot am Ende
vor Lewis Hamilton im Mercedes und
Fernando Alonso im ersten Marten wegen
verschiedener Unfälle war das Rennen auf
dem Kurs in Melbourne insgesamt dreimal
unterbrochen worden
und wir bleiben beim Sport in sieben
Etappen um die Welt fünf Yachten liefern
sich seit Januar das Ocean Race die wohl
spektakulärste Segelregatta der Welt die
dritte und schwierigste Etappe ist heute
morgen zu Ende gegangen von Kapstadt an
Australien vorbei rund um Kap Horn bis
nach Brasilien über
27.000 km 34 lange Tage der Gewinner der
deutsche Skipper Boris Hermann vom Team
malizia hätte zwischendurch fast
aufgegeben aber dann kam alles anders
Hermann Falke berichtet
am Ende eines fünfwöchigen Segeltörns
der ganz besondere nadys bei Boris
Herrmann und seiner Kuh die Euphorie und
zugleich Erleichterung allen halben zu
spüren und zu verstehen sowieso die
malizia landet als erstes in Brasilien
ab ich habe auch Energie jetzt aus der
Etappe gezogen weil es einfach so toll
ist zu merken wenn man wenn man versucht
irgendwie das Unwirkliche dann wieder
möglich zu machen dann kann man auch
wirklich belohnt werden und das ist so
ein bisschen das Märchen unserer unserer
Etappe unserer Etappe denn diese
königseetappe scheint für sie schon
beendet bevor es so richtig losgeht ein
Vorsegel gerissen und schlimmer noch der
Mast auch Brot welche gigantisches
Reparatur Vorhaben in fast 30 Metern
Höhe
wie auf einem Kirmes Pendel
der Kuh gelingt und fordern pflügt die
Sea Explorer 3 schier unwiderstehlich
durch Südpolarmeer entlang der
eisberggrenze
kompromissloses Segeln am Limit das
Schiff des deutschen erweist sich in
rauer See als das stärkste schnellste
und wohl auch sicherste Boot aber
Sicherheit ist in diesem Zusammenhang
vermutlich immer nur relativ
Gefahr lauert selbst im Schlaf wo sie
Körper wird bei einem heftigen Schlag in
einer hausruhen Welle aus der Koje
geschleudert die Niederländerin
ausgenockt mit Kopfverletzung und
Gehirnerschütterung leichte Entwarnung
erst am Tag danach danach
ich Flug von hier abrutschte etwa sechs
Meter runter bis ins leckwasser in der
Bild
dann wird's mytisch das sagenumwobende
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier haben Boris Hermann und Kuh die
Buchstütze Form
für mich ein erster Stelle ist fast
wichtiger als das ganze Rennen zu
gewinnen die Frage bleibt ja wie klein
ist eigentlich die Welt nach einer
windbetriebenen dreiviertel Runde um die
Erdkugel liefert sich malizia mit der
bislang unbesiegten Schweizer Holz im
PHB auf den letzten von mehr als 27
000 km einen irren Zielspurt
[Musik]
ohne Drama kann Boris Hermann offenbar
kein Logbuch schreiben bei der wohnt die
Globe vor zwei Jahren der Zusammenstoß
mit einem Fischkutter diesmal reist noch
ein Segel aber der 41-Jährige setzt sich
im letzten Sturm entscheidender
nach 34 Tagen 17 Stunden und zehneinhalb
Minuten gewinnt Team Alicia diese
härteste Etappe des Oceans wir waren bis
zuletzt unheimlich fokussiert und
konzentriert vor allem wollte ich nicht
wieder gegen den Fischerboot fahren und
äh das hat diesmal geklappt der Lohn
eine erste salzfreie Dusche nach genau
fünf Wochen vermutlich nicht die letzte
am heutigen Tag
Salz freie Dusche und wie immer am
Sonntag geht's hier jetzt weiter mit
unserem Ausblick auf wichtige Ereignisse
der nächsten Woche zusammengestellt von
Dalia Antar
[Musik]
Montag wollen Berliner CDU und SPD ihren
Koalitionsvertrag vorlegen das Bündnis
unter CDU landesschef Wegner und der
noch Regierenden spd-bürgermeisterin
Giffey ist umstritten auch unter den
spd-kreisverbänden die Basis ist gefragt
bis 23 April stimmt sie über den Vertrag
ab die CDU legt das Papier auf einem
Parteitag vor
Turbulenzen an den Börsen Rettungsaktion
notübernahme am Dienstag wird sich die
angeschlagene Schweizer bankredit Suisse
zur Hauptversammlung treffen nachdem sie
von der größeren rival in UBS für rund 3
Milliarden Euro geschluckt wurde die
Führung muss sich einstellen auf er
Booster Aktionärinnen und Aktionäre
Dienstag werden die
nato-außenministerinnen und Minister in
Brüssel erwartet nach der Zustimmung der
Türkei könnte der lang ersehnte
NATO-Beitritt Finnlands besiegelt werden
besprochen werden soll auch die
militärische Unterstützung der Ukraine
und der Umgang mit der China Russland
Allianz
in Moskau wird am Donnerstag der
belarussische Machthaber Lukaschenko auf
russlands Präsident Putin treffen
erwartet wird dass sie auch über die
Stationierung taktischer und
möglicherweise strategischer russischer
Atomwaffen in Belarus sprechen
und jetzt der Ausblick aufs Wetter dass
ich deutlich freundlicher zeigt in den
kommenden Tagen morgen scheint oft die
Sonne im Nordosten und an den Alpen ist
es stärker bewölkt aber nur selten
schneit es leicht bei mäßigen
Nordostwind werden drei bis 11 Grad
erreicht in den nächsten Tagen ändern
sich die Temperaturen kaum der Dienstag
wird überall freundlich ab Mittwoch kann
es im Osten hier und da regnen
das war es von uns hier geht es jetzt
weiter mit Vienna blood und den Mord
Ermittlungen im Wien der
Jahrhundertwende wir wünschen Ihnen noch
einen angenehmen Abend und morgen
begrüßen Sie hier Hanna Zimmermann und
Christian Sievers einen schönen Abend
tschüss tschüss
[Musik]